in treating recurrent glioblastoma
Davidsons your cancer expert I want to
ask you about this new Harvard study
that just came out on flight attendants
that showed that they have a higher
prevalence of every cancer that was
examined especially breast cancer
melanoma and non-melanoma what's going
on yeah so this is a questionnaire that
was given to flight attendants there
were 80% female and the questionnaire
showed that compared to controls these
are other people who are age match and
similar distribution that there was more
cancer was it their lifestyle they have
very strange hours they're up at night
they're up very early in the morning was
it the fact they're exposed to
carcinogens and fuel and other things on
the plane or was it the ionizing in the
UV radiation they're exposed to when
they're 30,000 feet in the air we don't
know there's an association here I
wouldn't change flight patterns yet but
these big data studies are gonna start
to come out as we see these and it's
hard to know whether it's association or
causality the trackage that the
challenge is to actually prove what's
causing things so this is an initial
data set hopefully more data will give
us answers and when they give us more
answers dr. agus will have you